welcome to this video playing attention
master drk dr. Danny coppedge I believe
that right I'm not sure if copper choose
the right right way to pronounce it and
what does he play together d3 line which
is very solid but of course also very
playable hmm I actually a plate b5 a bit
too quickly I usually play that with d6
and not such an Rudy be five I mean
nothing really terrible happened here
but it's not what I usually play
yeah an interesting idea is to play
something like this just guarding that d
5 square with this somewhat somewhat Tim
cookie night yeah and now i can probably
go back and also should go back some
there should be six is this possible he
has to trade then you know looks very
normal
ah maybe I should have taken only three
actually oh that's another two misstep I
should have should have taken this
opportunity to worsen his pawn structure
down now I have c4 actually I don't
quite understand his play okay yes but
that's it's really not not very
dangerous is it I can even go before in
this position okay but maybe then d
force is possible Queen B 7 is also also
in I think I can take all saying go
before this is actually that looks like
the simplest thing to do have to see for
yes absolutely nothing and otherwise i
will take and have a sound porn
structure with somewhat equal play okay
let's take them yeah night f-fire face
of course is his idea I can go with g6
just trying to prevent that there are
some possible tactics though yeah I
still think I should do it
Bishop age 69 f5 those kind of tactics I
definitely am I'm definitely lurking in
this position other thing is I can in
some cases may be employed d5 I just
wondered what happens if he goes Queen
a4 I said a move okay well I could have
just retreated i believe so here i would
love to trade to really like to trade
let's do this I can do this for it I
hope I'm not overlooking some kind of
silly tactic here there should be 797 is
quite quite decent I mean black
structures is pretty healthy if I'm not
getting getting killed with some with
some some tactical tactical blow yeah if
i take it Queenie seven Mikey egos queen
age six probably
yeah but there's nothing wrong with this
I think can't even do this cover things
with 97 here
see directly coming with f4l with them
with f5 maybe it looks kind of commuter
let's move of course I can take a knight
c6 maybe I should do that you cannot pin
this night least I don't see it and then
Knight to e5 timewise are ok I'd also
like to play 97 some time to get rid of
that Rukia always looking at my knight
on c6 and being somewhat somewhat
annoying them
Jim
I still a shrew come look 87 yeah
probably still I don't know look okay
tell ss6 is hanging does it really help
that much k i'm going for this Queen B 6
of course not a very sophisticated idea
okay so I wants to take on 70 what I can
takes you three hi morning okay
i'm also a one hanging maybe he goes for
Queen f2 or something like that what am
i doing then houki eight maybe a
covering stuff this okay let's just
cover stuff it's a bit passive don't
like it so much but what I mean cannot
g5 no doesn't lead anywhere and I check
that rook
yeah it's pretty active so I'm out for
96 I want to trade stuff to make things
a bit simpler and then I have a power
nap so I takes very long time now what
is he doing that one second Wow okay
maybe this is this ok I think I can
maybe do this like four things one time
yeah okay we're not entirely I just
don't want to make stupid moves damn I
think I'm probably in good shape now now
I'm the pawn up here with two looks
against against Queen tricky very tricky
the question really was if around here
if he had something something really
active them long-term opposition is this
really ok so this have six hella
computer agrees basically now it gives
pilots and that's an interesting move 98
for night f7 that makes lots of sense
guarding the hooking side I I did
something similar but now I had to og
five come on g5 well tactics 101 the
fork we attack night we attack a cuide
we win apiece that's too difficult for
me okay but I spotted the e5 square at
least I see some strategic ideas he had
them yeah yeah okay I mean besides g5 I
think I played it kind of okay keeping
keeping an advantage here in this in its
position
veggie 5 wasn't so difficult huh okay
well thanks for watching